it was kind of confusing how I wound up  taking over the black market and sex  trade of the whole city we all partied  every day like the world was coming to  an end  but I the party I was the party we  started out with nothing you've built on  us none of us to stop breaking the law  everyone else and paying my price this  serial killer is hosting videos on the  murders online  the streets would run with a black life  was short now sober I wanted to be drunk  [Music]  we're gonna stick together we're gonna  get through this  [Music]  I didn't even care about being in  control of the city anymore for some  reason I just was sometimes call this  white  you  you